It's funny cause I was talking about
this with a woman named Amy Aright,
who was one of the co founders of e
trade and,
uh,
Olivia cruises the other day.
We were on a panel together at a gay Mba
conference and we were talking a little
bit about what it,
what does it mean to be an entrepreneur
and what are the challenges?
And both of us sort of asserted that
there really weren't any as far as we
could tell.
And principally I believe that,
um,
there's still a ton of homophobia in the
world and there's a ton of homophobia in
the business world.
But because I've been very out and very
explicitly out in my life,
I'm in my professional life from the
beginning.
I just don't hear it.
So if you don't like me because I'm gay
or you don't want to do business with me
because I'm gay,
then I probably just don't even know
that because you're just steering clear
of me.
You know,
it's when you're closeted and people
don't know that you're gay,
that you hear and see the things that
are otherwise unsavory,
you know?
And I just,
I don't necessarily want to change
everybody's mind in the world about,
um,
you know,
about homosexuality or Judaism is I'm a
Jew and,
or you know,
any of the things that I'm passionate
about,
but I want to do.
One is I do want to be in an environment
in which I'm respected and I have an
equal opportunity to be successful.
And so I'm creating that every single
day by putting my parameters out there
and saying,
this is who I am.
I'm gay,
Jewish,
Chubby,
you know,
uh,
now in my mid thirties,
this is who I am.
And,
uh,
now you can self select out of my world
if you'd like.
And you know,
so be it.
I think one of the,
I think one of the challenges for all
gay professional people is this idea
that,
um,
you're going to be faced with a world
that's hostile to you and your lifestyle
and you know,
um,
but really it ends up being more
quotidian than that.
I think when you've worked,
especially in the corporate world,
which I mostly issued in my,
in my professional career.
But when you're working in the
professional world,
most of that hassle factor of being gay
is that you,
uh,
on Monday morning you come into the
office and your friends are talking
about their kids and their,
you know,
their spouse and what they did for the
weekend and the golfing that they did.
And if your lifestyle is not those
things,
if you're not a gay person with kids and
a spouse and golfing and you're sort of
forced to like interpret what part of
your life the other person does or
doesn't want to hear and what's
contextually relevant and you know,
what is or isn't going to make them
uncomfortable.
And I think,
um,
I think that's actually a complicated
dance,
um,
at first and then over time what you
realize is you gain traction on that.
So not being pollyanna.
I am saying that I think single straight
people have some of the same issues in a
culture where,
um,
you're ran a lot of married people are
married,
people with children.
There's a sort of expectation often
that,
uh,
people who are married with children can
go home at four o'clock because they
have to attend to their kids.
And of course who would say,
no,
you can't go pick your kids up from
school.
You know,
we're as the single person or the person
without kids.
It doesn't get to do things.
Um,
and then I think it's more,
I would like a family status equality,
fairness issue than it is a sexuality
fairness and equality issue.
And so a lot of,
so to me,
my observation has been that most issues
related to sexuality in the workplace
are actually issues of family status and
gender and rather than sexuality
strictly speaking.
And that,
um,
once you put those things into context,
then there's a layer of certainly of
like explicitly sexuality related
issues.
Um,
but most of it is about family status
and gender.
I will say one thing though,
which is I have the benefit of being an
entrepreneur and,
um,
the benefit of living in,
you know,
in the technology business and the games
industry and,
and being an entrepreneur in those
environments.
And so in those,
in the context of entrepreneurship and
technology and,
and the games industry,
um,
of course I can be out.
I mean,
it's my company.
So in that way I can build a corporate
culture that matches the environment
that I want to work in and are built
with people who I respect and who
respect me and who I feel comfortable
with and with whom I want to come into
work every single day and enjoy the,
you know,
basically the relationship that I'm
building with them.
You know,
and that's a degree of control that I
don't have in many other aspects of
being an entrepreneur.
But I certainly do in terms of who gets
hired to work at my company.
And,
um,
that's definitely one thing that's a
rewarding about being an entrepreneur
that you don't necessarily get when you
work in the corporate world.
So I appreciate it if you're,
uh,
you know,
if you're just starting out in your
career and you want to go work at,
you know,
some big tech finance company or the
Department of defense or something crazy
like that,
then your considerations are probably
different from mine.
But I,
I try to live a,
I work so much.
I try to integrate my life as much as
possible so that I can enjoy all aspects
of it.